what else?
Shelves shelves and books,
what's on the walls?
You
said more books but sometimes
there's pictures and posters and
all
kinds of fun things on the walls
. You had something to say.
There is pictures of people.
That's right.  Excellent
Sometimes there's pictures of
people and
sometimes those people are
authors and sometimes they're
famous people
and sometimes those people are
you guys, and I bet some of the
walls
are on the -- there's posters on
the wall and opportunities to
do all
kinds of activities with young
people like today when we have a
very
special author with us. I know
you all mow what authors are,
right?
What do authors do.
They write the books.
Right, they write the books.
Do they also illustrate the
books?
Sometimes. Well in this case, I
have a feeling all of you are
authors
too. Have you alien stuff? I
think you guys are.
Well, when you guys read
books, or when somebody reads
you a book
how often do you think about the
person who wrote the book?
That's my wish for you today
. I hope after this opportunity
to
meet an author today I hope that
every single book that you read
from
now on you think a little bit
about the author and the
illustrate for
of the book because when you
read a book and make a
connection of that
book you're making connection to
that author too and that's
really
special and also a connection to
anyone who will read the book,
and
that's special too. So I'm de
lighted to invite Shana Corey,
she's
going to talk about us today
about a book she wrote recently
about
John F. Kennedy and a very
important speech that he deliver
ed in 1963.
Now if he were still alive he
would be celebrating his 100
birthday
this month. Do you think that's
a long time? You're itching to
say
something, I'm going to call on
you and ask you to put your hand
s down
and so we can get started.
Sometimes people
paint the walls.
That's right. That's so true
. You guys are going to have a
chance
to say things later so please
put your hands down, let's give
a very
welcome to Shana and thank you,
we're so exciteed to hear from
you and
about the artwork that is also
here that your colleague
contributeed to
the book so thank you.
Thank you, I'm so excited to
be here you guys. This is a the
like mission control for
libraries,
that's pretty cool right?
Yeah.
Yeah. So I'm here today
because I'm an author but I want
always an
author -- do you want to see a
picture of me before I was
author?
Yeah.
This was me when I was about
your age maybe first grade.
Does that
look like me?
Yes.
So it would look like me if
I had a big red
bow -- who is that?
Madeline -- I love Madeline.
Madeline is a great book.
There's copies
in the back here so if you get
one tip from today if you want
to learn
to draw a big hair bow, two
triangles and you have your hair
bow.
Do you want to see what I
really looked like when I was
your age
this. was me when I was in
elementary school. Which one am
I? Raise
your hand if you think I'm the
one with braids no? Raise your
hand if
you think I'm the bossy big
sister? You guys? Hands down.
I'm the
bossy big sister. That's me and
my sister Marse.
Now I once an author yet in
that picture. Can you guys hear
me --
I wasn't an author yet in that
picture but I was doing
something that
was getting me ready to be an
author. What do you think I was
doing
when I was in first or second
grade to get ready to be an
author?
Reading books.
You guys don't -- raise your
hand if you love to read. Oh
good.
Then you guys, you're all on
your way to being authors
because read
something the most important
thing you can do if you want to
be an
author.
So when I was growing up
these were some of my favorite
books,
little house on the Perry, Betsy
Casey, I like reading so much
when I
grew up I decided I wanted to
have a job where I could be
around books
all day long. Can you guys --
what I don't knows where you can
be
around books all day long.
At the library.
You can be a librarian, and
this would be your office and
you
could take any books home you
wanted. That would be pretty
cool.
What kind of books can you
think of -- book jobs.
An author or an I will
administrator --
So you can write or draw the
pictures. What kind of book
jobs can
you think of?
I think you could be around
books
paint pictures.
You can paint pictures. This
book our Gregory
Christy, he painted
these pictures, he's around
books all day and then draws
pictures.
What kind of book job can you
think of?
One last book job that I can
think of is organizing books.
That's a really good one.
Organizing books. Do you think
librarian
librarians organize books? Yeah.
I'm wearing book earrings that's
true. I decideed to get a job
--
hold onto I don't thoughts --
being something called arch
editor, does
anyone know what's an editor?
Interesting. So that's part
of what an editor does, they
make sure
a lot of people are going to get
copies of the books.  I should
repeat
your answer so friends can hear
that are far away -- he said
editors
giveaway books. What else does a
an editor do.
I think an editor -- I don't
know.
I think an editor is like a
teacher. Do your teachers make
your
work better? So editors are help
authors to make their stories
better.
Here's my office in New York
City, I work at random house
children's
books, and it's just like I
always wanted. I'm surrounded by
books all
day long. I work on books for
big kids, early readers, and
they're
about history because I love
history, I do -- do you know the
George
Washington the general's dog? I
love that book. That's an
excellent
book.
So those -- it's really good
. I really recommend it. Those
books
are true story.
What's a book that has a
true story -- what's a book
called when
it's a true story?
When they read the book --
People read books to
children that don't have books.
What were you going to say?
What was the question again?
What's the book called when
the story is a true story?
Fiction.
Really close. Non-fiction.
Fiction is something that's
made up. Exactly.
So I also work on books -- I
have worked on series like baby
math
and another series that you guys
wouldn't know, I don't think,
no one
has ever heard of Jones? I love
it -- I have it in my backpack
too. I
love Judey B. Jones. After I had
been editing for a while I
decideed I
wanted to write my own story.
When you guys write stories
where do you
get your ideas?
From your brain.
Where do you get your ideas?
I get my ideas from books
From other books. That's a great
place.
Where do you get your ideas
from? So sometimes I get ideas
from
maybe
poetry.
That's fabulous, where do
you get your ideas?
I get my ideas from other
books because when I read a book
it
makes me think what I can do.
That's -- you guys are --
have such great ideas. Journals
to
poetry, because when she reads
books she gets idea ofs of what
else to
do. Where do you get your ideas?
From pictures. That's a
great idea. Anyone have one more
?
Pictures and facts. You guys
you sure you're first gradeers?
That's
really good answers. I get a lot
of ideas from facts because I
write a
lot of non-fiction.
You write non-fiction too --
I love non-fiction.
So put your hands down for a
second and I'll tell you some
of the
stories that I've written and
then we'll read the one about J
FK.
A lot of my stories -- can
you hear me? A lot of my stories
are
about real people, people that
inspire me. And I get inspireed
by
people who do things to create
change, like things they say I
want to
change the words.
Some of my first books are
about real lady that's liveed a
long
time ago and they didn't like
the clothes women liveed a lock
time ago
-- does anyone know about old
day cloths?
They would wear dresses.
They were wearing dresses,
long dresses. What else do you
know
about olden day clothes?
Sometimes they would only
wear halts because they're only
allowed
hats.
They had to wear hats and
bonets a lot of times. Are any
of you
guys going to go swimming this
summer? Yeah. Any of you going
to wear
a batheing suit that looks like
this? No? A long time ago women
used to
wear batheing suit that's looked
like this, but girls you're
going to
wear tights, you can't go
swimming without tights right?
Well this was
a lady has lived a long time ago
and she was a champion swimmer
and
she thought you can't win races
and set records in those kind of
bathe
bathing sites so she invented
her own batheing suit. That's
how batheing
suits were invented.
I write some book that's are
historic calfiction. Do you
know what
historical fiction is?
That's exactly right,
historical but fake, some parts
are true and
some are made up. So I'm going
to tell you which parts of this
are
true and which are made up. This
is about the all American girl
professional baseball league,
and it started during World War
II, all
of this is true because all of
the boys that played base you
ball went
off to the war. President
Roosevelt said you have to keep
baseball
going, so I did all the research
for this book, here's real
pictures
of the team, here's another real
picture, but I had a problem, I
because I had all the facts
about the
league, but I didn't have a main
character because there were so
many
people that played baseball in
this league. Hold onto your
thoughts.
Then it went to the library
because you can always find
facts and
answers at the library, right.
So I found this old book in this
secret
room on the third room of the
library -- I don't know if I was
suppose
supposed to be up there, there
were dusty old books and I when
I read
the book I got goose bumps
because this old book -- do you
know the
song take me out to the ball
game. Can you guys all together
say just
the first line of the song --
take me out to the ball game.
Okay, hold obtain your hats,
guess what? That's not really
the
first line of that song. When
they opened that book I couldn't
believe
it, there's a whole verse that
comes before that and that's the
kind
of stuff you can find when
you're researching in libraryies
, the first
line is Katie case ball mad, had
the fever and had it bad. When
I read
it I got goose bumps. When
everyone sing that's song about
baseball,
that song is really about girls
so I decided to make Katie Casey
my
main character. So that's why
it's historical fiction, my main
character is made up.
I've also written a book
about the first subway in New
York City.
And before I tell you about that
book I have a question, had
anyone
seen liter on the street? Has
anyone been struck in traffic?
Believe
it or not the liter in the
streets especially in New York
si was worse
150 years ago than today -- it's
so bad I don't know if I should
show
you a picture -- it's so gross.
You sure you want to see it --
this is
what the liter looked like 150
years ago. This was before state
cleaning, before recycleing, and
the streets are a mess.
So, they were gross -- and
can anyone tell me how did
people get
around 150 years ago? How did
they get around?
Horses pulled people in cart
s some if there were a lot of
horses
on the streets what else was on
the streets that horses produce
ed?
YesYes, horse poop. So the
streets were really, really
gross, there's
another picture. Although they
hadn't invented things stoplight
s, they
hasn't invented stop signs or
stoplights or even lines there's
no lane
lanes in that picture because
traffic was new so this man
named Alfred
had an idea, he was going to
invent a subway. You rode the
Metra here?
You just -- he wanted to invent
a different kind of subway, a
subway
that ran on knew mattic power.
Do you annoy what that is do you
know
what Newman tic power?
It's the subway stays --
stays old forever?
Stays on forever. That's a
good thought. Will you be my
volunteer.
I need someone to doll tear.
Are you really good at
science?
Yes.
We have a scientist here who
is going to demonstrate knew
mattic
power for us. Can you take this
and blow it.
I have a question for you --
I didn't see you take your hand
and
move that, what force can you
use to move that. Wind, air. And
that's
what knew mattic power is, it's
air power.
So he he used area power --
you want to hold onto that. You
can
have it at the end.
Request we give her a round
of.
(APPLAUSE) applause.
So they used air to move the
subway back and forth.
The book I'm going to read
today is about this person. Who
is that
that? John F. Kennedy, who would
be 100 at the end of this month
.
And he inspireed me because
he's a real person and he had a
decision to make if he was going
to be brave and stand up for
something he believed in. So
should we read the story and see
what he
did.
I'm going to see if I can
put this here so I can turn the
pages in
my book and be a little up
closer.
A time to act. What's a book
called when it's about a person
? Do
you know the name? Yes?
Biology. Biography, so this is a
biography of
John F. Kennedy and it's non-
fiction.
I'm going to read it here
and turn the pages.
John F. Kennedy loves to
read about history, but history
isn't
just in books it's happening all
around us and the people that
make
history aren't just famous
leaders, they're real people
just like you,
sometimes they are you.
John or Jack as he was
called was a second of nine
children in a
big rich family. If you saw the
Kennedy's you might think they
had
everything. But take a closer
look, Jack wasn't the favorite,
that was
his big brother Joe. The father
wanted Joe to grow up to be the
President. Jack didn't always do
well in school. He is call all
and
disorderly and could sell his
possessions and he was often
sick. But
he was funny and people liked
him. When Jack was too sick to
play
outdoors he read.
Jack's mother taught her
children the importance of
giving back to
one's country. Jack too that
belief seriously. John joined
the fight
on August 2, 1943 the end me
ship ripped into the boat he
commanded he
led the survivors to safety,
towing one of the injured three
miles
while he swam.
I'm reading -- I'm not
reading the whole thing because
I want to
have time for questions and for
me to show you how it became a
book.
Jack's brother Joe also
serveed the country. Jack was
killed flying
over the English channel. The
family was heart broken. Now it
was up
to Jack to carry out his father
's dreams for Joe. In 1946 Jack
ran for
Congress. The whole family
helped. After six years as
congressmen, he
was electricity to the the
Senate. They loveed his
-- Jack had back
surgery, while he recovered he
wrote another book with the help
of his
staff. It told about people who
had the courage to take a stand
for
things they believed in. Even
when they weren't popular. Have
you guys
ever done something really brave
?
What have you done that's
really brave? Jack was --
Going into a pool is really
brave, especially if you're not
sure
about it.
What else have you done
that's really brave?
Oh, wow, jumping into
a pool is a really brave thing.
You guys are a bunch of brave
kids.
On January 2, 1960, Jack
announceed he was running for
President --
into a powerful speaker but not
everyone thought he would win.
Do you think it would be run to
office
if you think people would say
you couldn't win.
He was 42 years old, younger
thanmy President-Elected before
.
President Eisenhower called him
--
My deer boy, I only say
these things for your own good,
and Jack
was Catholic. Many people
believed that the country
wouldn't
electricity a Catholic. I
believe the religious in
tolerance will some
day end said Jack. That is --
that picture is behind it.
A long hard struggle over
civil rights. Civil rights for
the right
of all people to be treated
fairly without being
discriminated against
against. In many places back
medium were not treated fairly,
in the
south especially, a thing called
segregation kept black people
from
white people -- especially the
Supreme Court -- it's just down
the
from -- had declareed it illegal
, black people were not allowed
to go
to the same people as white
people, they were not allowed to
eat in
the same restaurants or stay in
the same hotels. They couldn't
get the
same jobs as white people and
sometimes they were kept from
voting.
Many Americans like Martin
Luther chingjunior and other
people
that were not famous, even kids
like you guys were frying to
change
that through a peaceful protest.
Have you ever been to a peace
ful
protest? You're already part of
history. You're a part of
history just
like the people in this book.
You're working to change history
and
make history. That's how you
make history by being part of it
and you
guys are already doing that.
The women's March?
So we can show Donald Trump
we're stronger.
Love is stronger.
That's fabulous. So you're
part of history. You guys are
changing
history, you're making your
voices heard and telling people
how you
want our country to be. Good job
all of you.
So here are more kids part
of protest. Just a month later
four
College students began a sit in,
do you know what a sit in is?
It's a
protest when you're sitting to
make a statement. So I'll read
about it
it.
They sat quietly and peace
fully and waited to be serveed,
they were
refused. Every day more and more
students joined them.
By the end of the week the
it spread across the country --
that
October Martin Luther King was
arrested and sent to prison for
participating in a sit in. His
wife Coretta Scott King feared
he would
be killed.
Some of Jack's advisors
worryied it would cost him the
votes of
white people that doesn't
support civil rights. Do you
think that
stopped him or he wanted to help
Martin Luther King.
If there's anything I can do
to help please feel free to
call on
me. He was elected the
35th President for the
eyewitness. Hold onto
your thoughts and we'll do
questions at the end.
Some things the President
acted -- thank you -- some
things the
new President acted quickly and
used bold words. He established
the
Peace Corp and challenged young
Americans to go out in the world
and
work shoulder to shoulder with
other countries. The United
States and
the Soviet Union
were rivals. The Soviet union
had sent someone to
space. Jack said the United
States would be the first to
have a man
land on the moon. Among other
things, important civil rights
issues,
Jack was slow to act. He once
declareed that the President
must be
willing to get in the thick of
the fight but now he seemed
unwilling
to fight some battles. I would
like to be patient but patience
has
cost us years in our struggle
for human
dignity. Others were taking
action.
And that made despite the
danger hundreds of black
children and
teenagers stood up again and
enact the. They left their
classrooms in
Birmingham Alabama and marched
peacefully, they were hauled off
to
jail. The next day mother people
arriveed to take their places.
In the
civil rights movement a lot of
young people were at the
forefront
saying we have to do something
different, we have to make our
voices
heard. Americans including Jack
saw the downpeople's courage by
on the
news and sickened by the
violence.
On June 11th,two students
tried to join the University of
Alabama, do you think Jack is
going to act now? He had to act.
And
finally, following in the
footsteps of those who have set
the course
by sitting in and sending letter
s, March be and riding buss he
did.
Jack ordered the national
guard to escort the children
safely into
school. That night in living
rooms and kitchens and dineers
across the
America, millions of people of
all colors, rich people, poor
people,
people from the North and people
from the South, people of
different
religions, people who have
looked the other way and people
who have
fought for change turned on
their television and radios and
heard the
President speak.
This is some of what he said
. He said 100 years has delayhas
past
since President Lincoln has
freed the slaves. This nation
will not be
fully free until all citizens
are free. Now the time has come
for this
nation to fulfill its promise
it's a time to act.
So after the speech Martin
Luther King and the paw baseball
player
Jackie Robinson sent letters
good job. The presidential
statement on
the color question is one of the
-- sometimes they had said
they need
to end segregation but they
never said it's totally and
completely
wrong. They made it sound it was
about politics and Jack Kennedy
said
it's just wrong.
The following week he sent a
strong civil rights bill to
Congress.
So do you think he sent it
right across the street to the
Senate
building. You guys are right in
the place where all of this
happened.
President was killed November 22
, 1963, just a few months after
he
addressed the nation of civil
rights but his legacy lives on.
Today
the Soviet Union no longer
exists but young Peace Corps
still go out
in the world building bridges,
libraryies and schools.
On July 20, 1969, Kennedy
space challenge was met, two
American
astronauts walked on the moon.
And on July 2, 964 with help of
many
courageous people the civil acts
-- civil rights act was enacted
--
provideing for the integration
for schools and public places.
Hold on one second -- in the
50 years since the bill was
passed
there's been much progress on
civil rights but there's a been
a step
backwards too. History isn't a
straight line, and it's not
written in
permanent ink. We're changing
every day. When you go to
protest you're
changing history. From here on
out you are the decision makeers
Jack
once told young people. You are
the writers of history, so now
it's
your turn to choose your course
torque speak up, to act, to move
the
world forward, to make history,
so kids your age can and have
made
history. Do you guys want to see
how this story became a book
and then
we'll have time for questions.
When I first wrote this, the
first thing I do is I look for
inspiration, you talk about
where you get your ideas, I get
a lot of
ideas from photographs these are
some of the real pictures of
John F.
Kennedy's family, I know you saw
some family memory beia
upstairs --
he's right in the middle in the
back.
Even more, as much as I was
inspireed by John F. Kennedy I I
was
more inspireed by the people he
was inspireed by, the people
that were
creating the change, those brave
kid that's were showing the
courage.
Who is that?
Everyone knows -- you guys
-- I can't get over this -- they
are so
smart. Yeah, that's Ruby bridges
, she was the first black
student in
elementary school.
Why did she have to go to
the white kids school?
She wanted to. She hadn't
been allowed to. The school
that's white
people went to had better
resources, they had more money,
so she
wanted to have the same things
-- she deserveed just as good
and
education as everyone else right
?
That's a very good question.
You know, you notice
sometimes when some people think
-- some
people are worried that they
share with people they won't
have as much
much, I think if had to do with
that. Some people felt they want
ed to
keep all the good stuff and keep
the other people out, and they
want
the all the good stuff. It
wasn't a fair system. The
Supreme Court
said it wasn't fair. So now we
can be together.
I was also inspireed --
these are some of the real kids
-- maybe in
the March, when the kids left
their classroom? Here's some of
the real
kid that's marched just like
when you guys said you had March
ed
recently. And I was inspireed by
those kids. When I started
reading
about Kennedy, I wanted to write
about the kids that inspireed
him. I
started writing and found old
documents, this is a letter that
he
wrote whether or not he was a
little boy. There's a telegram,
that
says my deer boy, and then they
started writing -- my rough
drafts are
kind of messy -- I don't know in
if I should show you? Yeah?
This is
my rough draft for my baseball
book.
If you were in a library and
you could check out any book
you
wanted how many would get that
if you saw it on the shift? Not
many
right?
What's it missing -- what's
it need before it can be a book?
It's missing pictures,and
it's missing
a front page.
It's missing a pictures, a
title page, what else?
It's also missing
a title. If it had a title it
would actually be
a book.
Okay, one more. What does it
need before it can be a book?
A book with
-- pictures on it.
Not all books have pictures.
You're absolutely right. It is
pretty
messy. Should we do one more --
what were you going to say? It's
miss
ago period.
It probably is. I think it's
missing correct spelling, it's
missing pages, it's pretty messy
. So what I do after my first
draft I
revise. What does revise mean?
You do it again. Yeah, so I
keep working on it to make it
better
and better, and when it's as
good as I can possibly make it I
type it
up -- here's a type up version I
did about a girl scout and then
I
send it to my editor. How many
people think my editor will say
it's
perfect and we'll publish it
just like this? Yes, it's never
happened.
Instead she sends it back to me
full of ideas of how I can
revise it
back to me.
And all of those are
comments about ways I can make
the story
better. I think in this one the
only thing she said I could keep
was
the main character's name and
that's because is it was non-
fiction.
Egg else she wants me to change
and try to make it better. If
we're
going to make you guys read it
we're going to make it good. The
last
thing we do is send it to the I
will administrator and they do
some
sketches. So that's what the
sketches looks like before he
does the
beautiful paintings. Covers,
they can take a really long time
. They're
revised to get stories right, I
will administrators revise.
Here's the
art for that. Here's some of
what Greg Christy did when he
was working
on the cover. Here's what the
final cover looks like. So you
guys can
see -- these are some things he
was experimenting with different
ideas
ideas, getting different ideas
downMaybe he was thinking maybe
we
should have Kennedy walking to
the podium?
All these different ideas --
when we're talking about these
we had
a thought. It's great to see
Kennedy in these but what was
Kennedy's
big inspiration, who inspireed
Kennedy. Who inspireed Kennedy?
Who made
I am give his speech? Martin
Luther King, and also who else?
And also the kids. But
you're right, they said you need
to do more
and they were met by violent and
he thought if they can do it we
have
to do something.
So our Grege Christy thought
the kids need to be on the
front
cover too because they're
important as Kennedy, at least.
The time cover, he brought
the real kids, and he worked
them into
the illustration. The thing that
makes you do something.
That was Kennedy's
inspiration. And everything I
was going to tell
you guys about today -- do you
guys have questions for me? Yes
yes,
questions?
Why did -- if you were
making a -- good question.
That's a a
-- artists they always can make
their decisions on what
they think looks the best. I
think -- if you put words on it,
it might
distract from the title. Good
question.
Yeah?
So I kind of have an answer
-- so, maybe -- maybe
the back of the
slide was actually supposeed to
be belly paper.
We could be looking at the
back of the sign there. That's a
good
thought.
Okay. We'll come back. Yeah?
Why did he -- did he have a
funeral? Kennedy? Yeah, he did.
When
he died, it was in November, the
same thing he gave the speech,
he had
a big funeral.
Any other questions?
To write this book?
I was interested in writing
about Kennedy because I knew it
was
his 100est birthday, but I knew
he was President during the
civil
rights movement and I didn't
know what his involvement was. I
had read
those two parts of history
separately, I read about Kennedy
, and I
read about the sit in and Ruby
bridges, I thought what he was
doing --
he was the President and had to
be involved in. So I thought to
do
research and see what he was
doing. Good question. Yes?
What do I like in the book
about Kennedy? My favorite piece
of art
art, it's not here, it's a piece
of art with all the kid kids
watching
television. I find that powerful
, you see kids all over, some
from the
South, some from the North, and
I thought it must be powerful
for a
President to stand up to
something that you know is right
.
The book that Kennedy wrote
called profile and courage about
brave
people, there are awards, and
they just gave them out this
past week.
Guess who got the profile and
courage award? This year it went
to
President President Obama -- he
was your favorite President? You
can
hear his speech. He talked about
Kennedy, which was neat.
He is very famous. Yes?
How come Luther King got
shot --
It didn't end right away. It
ended with the civil rights,
and
before the civil right acts
there was a supreme course case
that said
there shouldn't be segregation.
History can take a long time.
Change
happens slowly. We want it to
happen faster but change happens
slowly.
It would be nice if it ended
right away. I think you have to
keep
working for things because
sometimes it's like we can relax
and think
something is all done. They've
gone forward but we slide
backwards too
too, so we have to keep marching
and keep protesting for things
we
believe in. Yes?
Why did the guy shoot him in
the fairest place -- Kennedy or
Martin Luther King?
You meant Kennedy?
I think -- I honestly don't know
. I think he didn't agree with
them.
He -- I think a lot of times
-- it's dangerous being a
President.
That's why President's have
secret service. Have you seen
secret
service? Yeah, they do a lot
more safety things like they use
ed to do.
They don't have open cars and
stuff so the President can be a
little
safer. If you have concerns to
peacefully protest versus
violence. Yes
Yes?
I know that -- so, when I
saw a picture,
I thought -- I knew it
was going to be like that
because the book in the red
writing, it says
John F. Kennedy's big speech.
It does say that.
So -- I'll tell you a few
behind the scenes thing about
that
picture. When we first saw the
paintings it was all in color,
and
that's something the artist
revised, what do you guys know
about
television from a long time ago?
Yeah, a lot of TVs were black
and
white. So he had to go back and
change the art. That probably
wouldn't
have been in color. And we did a
lot of the title, a time to act
comes
from the speech he gave, and we
debateed it should be John F.
Kennedy O
J FK's big speech because a lot
of people called him J FK --
what
would you guys have done? Fit
Gerald -- yes.
Back then, he was
invented --
It was invented --
>>
I saw real life TV way back
then and
--
That is really brave, a lot
of people did brave water things
some
TV was just invented. A lot of
people listen to it on the radio
and they didn't have the
Internet. You
can actually watch the speech.
You can go online and your
teacher can
find it, you can watch videos on
this speech. It's on my website
or
the J FK library.
All not all the people that
helped our country is black, not
all
of them.
You're right. There were
white people and other people
that helped
too, allyies.
Yes? Of if I know the last
name of the person who killed
John F.
Kennedy. His last name is Oswald
. You're right.
What month was his funeral?
You know, he died in
November, November 22nd, I don't
off hand
know the date of his funeral but
I bet it was still November.
Is it the one the four friends
-- I love that book. That's a
wonderful book. There are
wonderful books about the sit in
s. Yeah,
there's a wonderful book about
the -- there's several wonderful
books
about Martin King -- there are
Self-wonderful books about Ruby
King --
she wrote some kid's books. I
don't know if you kids get to
read books
after. Are they reading books? I
bet you'll have a lot of these
bookbooks
in your school.
Did the person who got --
who killed J F Kennedy, did he
get hang
hanged?
That's a good thought. He
was shot. Someone --
You guys know about Kennedy
--
Who killed Oswald?
Jack rubey. And there's things
about that too. So this book is
about Kennedy and civil rights
but there's a lot of great book
that's
talked about his assassination,
some picture books.
Yes.
The person who killed J F
Kennedy and the person who shot
the
President shot the -- who shot
that person?
It was a really intense time
. It was all -- no, I don't
believe it
happened all in the same day.
When was this book made?
This book -- good question
-- it just came out last month.
It was
just published but I really
wrote it last year because it
takes a long
time for the ill administrator
gets to their work after it's
already
written so I wrote it and then
it went to the I will
administrator.
Yes?
When did
the
segregation end?
Good question. So I believe
-- what were you going to say --
When did slavery end.
1859 --
We celebrate on the 4th of
July because that's when our
first
attendance was wrote. You're
right -- George Washington was
in the
revolution air war and was the
first President.
So I think segregation, it
took longer to actually end to
when it
became I legal.
So we kind of noticed
there's a Paul person Paul
revere -- I know
about a person named Paul revere
too.
It's part of American history,
and he has to do with the
American
revolution too.
Yes?
Good question. So right now
I'm write ago book about
Michelle
observe.
Obama. Was the person that kill
ed
J FK arrested? Yes. You guys
have been a wonderful audience
with fabulous questions and
answer. Can